[Musique]
il est le nouveau patron du parti
communiste français le nordiste fabien
où seul élu ce dimanche à la tête d'un
parti en pleine crise et -2 3% dernières
législatives patron mais pourquoi faire
quel élan données quelles alliances
aussi pierre weillaert
un nouveau nom s'affiche à la tête du
parti communiste fabien roussel vient
d'être élue sans surprise secrétaire
national du parti
dans l'assistance le père de fabien
roussel militant communiste et ancien
journaliste à l'humanité il va là où au
fond le plus donc sur le lieu de travail
dans les quartiers déshérités c'est ce
qui fait pour moi un homme un vrai
communisme donc tu pour moi c'est un
grand jour mon fils entrent dans
l'histoire soizic fait partie des 736
délégués régionaux venus voter ce
dimanche pour eux fabien roussel incarne
un nouveau souffle il a son franc-parler
moyennant du nord donc
beaucoup de personnes du nord pour comme
ça mais son côté cash on enlève rien au
fond politique qui la mène et aux
batailles qui mène notamment sur
l'évasion fiscale dont il a pris la
suite en pédalant banquiers l'enjeu pour
fabien roussel et de renouer avec les
classes populaires le pc a réalisé moins
de 3% à l'élection présidentielle le
monde ouvrier il s'en parlait il le
connaît et c'est le retour du monde
ouvrier dans le parti communiste
français le parti de l'international va
devoir repartir à la conquête des
territoires
[Musique]